we just got done watching the season
eight finale of when calls the heart
elizabeth and lucas on the bridge
together
they've decided to start a courtship
i hoped i'd find you here
[Music]
erin what's your immediate reaction i'm
very happy
and i'm very sad it was just never going
to be diplomatic
diplomatic answer well it's situated
i hope that i'm validating what probably
many of the hardys are feeling which is
like
very mixed feelings we have been
blessed with kevin and chris who have
done such an incredible job
bringing these characters to life and
it's impossible
not to uh as a viewer
fall in love with the characters they've
created it's just impossible not to
so i'm i'm really excited about this
next chapter for elizabeth
getting to see her happy and free
and in love i think that'll be a really
positive thing to get to play
but um but yeah my feelings are are
mixed if i'm being honest
kevin how did you feel when you read the
scripts this decision
i think was right up until the very end
you know there's many
i've read many comments being like oh
you know they're
they're wine they're weaving us through
this like carefully orchestrated
thing but i mean the truth is that a lot
of the time
hallmark all of us were kind of still
kind of figuring out what was best what
was the best way to go
so when when we did finally come to that
conclusion i
i think it does open up for some really
interesting storylines moving into
into next season chris i want to ask you
how do you feel about
being the suitor that she chose in the
end i think that lucas is ecstatic he
did his best to show her how he felt
and tried to be patient and took his
time obviously there were hiccups along
the way but
i think he said in i can't remember if
it was season six or season seven but he
said i'll uh i'll wait as long as i have
to
um to for the woman of my dream
something something in that neighborhood
so
i think he's mostly just relief
and uh and excitement for the future
you're all that matters
you're all that's important thank you
for waiting for me
in the end what do you think it was
ultimately for elizabeth that made her
decide
lucas is really the right fit for me for
a long time
um elizabeth has just
been kind of confused and overwhelmed by
her feelings
and specifically the connection that
she's felt with nathan
over these past few years it is
undeniable there's been a connection
between these two characters
and i think for a long time she was
swept up in
those feelings with nathan but didn't
necessarily realize how much of it was
because of jack and what she was
almost projecting onto nathan
and so once she got to a point where she
could
see the difference between why she was
feeling what she was feeling for nathan
and what she'd been feeling all along
for lucas
i think it became clear to her that one
was
absolutely love but the other was
the other was hopefully her lifetime
that's going to be the person that she
is in love with
her next great love story the decision
for elizabeth and lucas to be together
was that something you knew going into
season eight or was this kind of like a
last minute
uh up against the clock we got to figure
this out sort of deal
i will say the decision was made
in season eight it was not made in the
first episode
it was a very long drawn-out decision
that involved many voices and brains
and um yeah it took a really long time i
think
we would have been in really great shape
with either decision it just would have
been a slightly different story
we have to talk about this absolutely
breathtaking moment
on the bridge the two of your characters
they reunite and they share
what i feel is is such a grand and
cinematic
kiss what was that day like on set what
kind of conditions were you filming in
did it feel different knowing that you
were filming like such an important
scene
the conditions were poor i'm not gonna
lie
it was a really uh it was just sort of a
scary day we
we had saved this very important scene
for the final day of filming
and you know we can't control the
weather and we were expecting this
really bad
windstorm there was conversation the
night before of
what do we do do we move the scene do we
move it inside elizabeth's row house
and chris and i both felt pretty
strongly
like the scene couldn't happen in
elizabeth's living room
it had to happen somewhere that as you
said felt cinematic
that was a place that was special to
them luckily all we got was a bit of a
drizzle
and i think it turned out i think it
turned out beautiful i was just
massively stressed out because it was uh
we were waiting for this
huge rainstorm to come in the winds were
picking up you know branches were
cracking
we're all we can use we don't have time
we don't have time like we can't do this
you know is it safe is it not there was
a lot there was a lot
but at the end of the day it all came
together for lucas it's
it's a very powerful moment i think they
just
both intuitively understand each other
and
know that they've come to the same place
and common ground and that they can
finally come together
no strings attached and and move forward
we wanted it to feel
like it was this explosion
of their passion and emotion
right and that it wasn't just like one
sweet romantic kiss
it was just like this i now that i have
you
i don't want to take my hands off you
kind of feeling
it's almost like the dialogue is
secondary
in a way okay well just when i thought
my heart couldn't explode anymore than
it it did
you gave us an unbelievable final scene
in the episode for now
[Music]
i'm afraid she's all out of words
[Music]
why did you feel that this scene was a
great way
to to tie up season 8 with a bow it's
just like a little bonus it's a little
extra
getting to see those two people happy
together and i think
in addition to it being an opportunity
for us to get to see lucas and elizabeth
happy together it's just nice to see
elizabeth
with a smile on her face and so i think
ending season eight on a on a positive
note
um it's our promise to the fans of good
things to come
to quote kevin mcgarry from i believe an
earlier conversation we had
it looks like this time it was elizabeth
who went to the mercantile and bought
out the entire
all the candles yeah all the candles
everywhere else in whole valley
nobody can get any light nathan i do
love you
it'd be impossible not to
but i'm not in love with you
i'm just so sorry how do you feel nathan
handled it what was it like being in
that scene
did that scene that was all air and i
just remember like thinking i just gotta
listen and take this
in that's all i gotta do and we heard
the connor or one of the
the grip i think he was on my coverage
and aaron was like given that monologue
right where she knows but
like it's a break it's a very
beautifully written breakup
and i'm just sitting there taking it and
then i think we heard kind of go
oh that's brutal
[Laughter]
it was written that mason thanked her at
the end so i
i thought you know we always the fans
have been with this like you got to see
him getting
he got to see him get his heart broken
essentially and i just thought it was
better if he didn't say anything and he
just took that in
how is he doing you think he's
heartbroken gutted
or are you thinking yeah yeah i think he
is totally heartbroken yeah i mean you
know he
he'll go on we all get broken hearts and
that'll be you know a fun
you know fun thing to play i hope he has
some kind of redemption story of him you
know
building himself back up and and moving
on
what does this next chapter of life for
nathan
look like i think you know there should
be a little bit of
mourning that we see at the beginning of
season nine that that
nathan's gonna have to go through what's
so cool is that both these guys are
still
like on the show so we get to see these
after stories we've always all seen
you know the guy against the girl and
the happy ever after but like the guy
that doesn't
is still on the show so there's this
whole different
you know storyline that's going to come
out of it i think for sure we'll see
nathan's bond with ali grow that kind of
comedy
you know of this guy raising a daughter
now as a as
a father figure with no kind of female
input how do you think she's gonna
handle still having elizabeth as her
teacher
but knowing that her uncle isn't with
the woman that she wants him to be with
i think she's gonna move into
season nine i think she's gonna be more
interested in her own love life i don't
want to feel like when she's 14
like i i think she's made peace with
that i think she knows
uncle nathan's fine he's been through
worse but now i think she's
i mean it'll be interesting to see she's
got her eye on robert
yeah well i mean nathan just got his
heart broken now he's going to deal with
the young love love life of his niece
from one kid to another from ali
i want to talk a little bit about little
jack of course now that
lucas is absolutely gonna be a heavier
presence in elizabeth's life
um chris what can you tell me about the
hopeful
bond that we'll get to see between jack
and lucas
well i hope we get some scenes uh that
don't get cut
this is what happened this year we did
one oh that literally got cut
lucas gave little jack the toy dog or
something like that
and said that after a little every
little boy needs a dog i'm looking
forward to next season and working more
with the taylor twins and seeing lucas
in more of a father figure role
i have to congratulate the three of you
such huge news
when calls the heart coming back for
season nine is there a
storyline that you're most excited to
tell in season nine
i am really interested in figuring out
what the friendship is like between
elizabeth and nathan
i love working with kevin
and i'm just really excited to see
what that dynamic is and
how they move forward with each other
um and i mean obviously we talked
a lot about how exciting it'll be to get
to bring lucas
into the little thornton family and see
what that is like
i guess i guess what i'm trying to say
is i can't wait to get back to work
we'll both kevin and chris
ah john did send me something recently
that was like i really want to do this
with your character
don't tell anyone and i was like okay so
i don't know what is it what is it
you like the idea it would be a trip
yeah it would be a big thing if it
happened
i'm looking forward to exploring the
relationship farther
between lucas and elizabeth i kind of
think
that it might be fun on a personal level
for lucas
who has always done quite well
financially to maybe run into some
trouble and see
what it looks like when everything is
taken away of course we've been on this
journey with the three of you for the
last three seasons
what do you have to say to the the team
nathan fans and the team lucas fans
now that there's been a conclusion to
this love triangle
well i have to say thank you to them
for being uh patient
with us i'm so so happy that
both kevin and chris are sticking around
and that we're gonna get to continue to
tell these stories together
nathan is gonna be just fine like he's
gonna be
great in fact and and kevin it's
probably most
important that they hear it from you
because kevin's gonna be just fine too
so how are you feeling kevin the team
lucas fans i'm very happy that you got
what you wanted that it's gonna go the
way you want
i hope you enjoy it and and to the team
nathan fans hey guys
uh nathan here um look i'm
i'm sorry it didn't go the way that you
wanted it but you know thank you for all
the support that you gave
nathan um but you know at the end of the
day
it is it's about elizabeth's happiness
and
her heart with lucas so we gotta we
gotta be happy for
for elizabeth but team nathan
and team lucas i think it's time to come
together and beat teamwork valley